harnessing the energy of the wind is
really nothing new here in Rhode Island
they've been doing it for almost 200
years
a lot of people move yachts from here to
the Caribbean or whatever by ship that's
how I get my yacht to the Caribbean
that's right
I'm so happy I could cry from the day
this starts generating power it runs in
the black the town will be saving money
oh my gosh after five years that's gonna
happen amazing
we got a multi-million dollar
organization going out here we got to
worry about the time put all that weight
onto one crane that weight transfers
down into soil compression right here
we're on the edge of the waters those
bulkhead holding back the soil we could
bust out the shoreline on the soil rush
out into the water and be kind of a
nightmare
I am marine disaster yeah so we'd like
to avoid so not today at least
just keeps getting better yeah that's
gonna be a problem
trailer can't back up trailers in
multiple pieces the truck stuck in a
ditch oh you're gonna get relic I know
Chris - Noah rabbits gonna bring in his
truck and try to pull out relics been
bragging about his truck actually for
why he's been bragging about it we're
gonna see we're gonna see
wasn't a good noise for a driveline
stars are against us today
struggling struggling with this one
Brothers in Arms all waiting for the
same thing
quick time yeah
I don't think maybe you let your cigar a
little too early this piece here is
called in a sentence they're really
houses the guts of the turbine even here
on the ground the road is being blown
around pretty good the way this rotor is
specifically designed to catch the wind
makes it by far the most challenging
piece to lift the main tower this wind
turbines over 200 feet tall we'll put it
up in three sections Riley yeah hey man
we got to put this thing up you guys are
done screwing around let's go
you got a boss oh here we go all right
let's go on the ground but I'm here at
the top of the tower it's really crooked
all righty this is the deal I got my
hand out the top in the cell here it's
kind of hard to take a reading actually
because the snow keeps freezing the
anemometer but I'm getting some
mid-thirties pretty consistently high
gusts of 45 thanks Riley 50 mile an hour
guts there's no way we're gonna lift
this thing in this weather
50 feet shy to live here and it's
twisted annoying they're trying to hold
it steady but if they can't get this
thing under control they say it's not to
set it down it's still spinning and
that's a real pucker for everybody
because if the load swings around with
the way to make contact with the boom it
can collapse the whole